This is just completely predictable, but also
disastrously humiliating. We have now learned
that a close ally per CNN of Georgia Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green participated,
participated in the January 6th riots in
Washington, DC, and was among those who
ultimately made their way into the building.
We've been covering Marjorie Taylor Green
as one of quite a few Trumpy radical right wing
members of Congress that won solely because of
their support of Donald Trump and
Marjorie Taylor Green in particular,
has been promoting all sorts of conspiracies
and dangerous ideas. She encouraged the idea,
untrue idea that the election was somehow stolen
by Joe Biden from Donald Trump. She tweeted that
those who broke into the Capitol weren't even
really Republicans. They were antifa dressed
up as Trump supporters. But unfortunately, a guy
named Anthony Agüero, a conservative live streamer
activist and associate of Marjorie Taylor Green's,
is on video saying he was among those who entered.
It wasn't done by Antifa. It was really pro Trump
Republicans who did it. He said, quote, on video,
we were all there. It was not antifa and it was
not Black Lives Matter. It was Trump supporters
that did that yesterday. I'm the first to admit
it, being one myself. I walked among all those
people. This is a close associate of
Marjorie Taylor Green's Green and Guro
worked closely together on immigration related
issues. The border wall. They went to pro Trump
rallies together. A bunch of videos have since
been deleted, but Marjorie Taylor Green has
called O'Gara amazing and a friend and a
girl called Green, one of my closest friends.
This is an associate of Marjorie Taylor Greens,
who was an activist with Marjorie Taylor Green,
who is at the Trump riots and participated
in the Trump riots. Now, will there be any
repercussions for Marjorie Taylor Green
as a result of this? I don't think so.
I don't think so at this point. We have seen that
you can essentially get away with anything in the
Republican Party without having to resign, without
having repercussions. It was even shocking to me
that Marjorie Taylor Green was stripped of her
committee assignments because of the things that
that she said in the aftermath of the January 6th
riots. But the only way out of this is she has to
be soundly defeated in twenty, twenty two. Now,
I'm already seeing all sorts of very confident
statements that Marjorie Taylor Green is facing a
bloodbath for reelection in 2022. She's going to
be soundly defeated. It's going to be humiliating.
She's going to be made a one term congresswoman.
Let's ease up on that a little bit. It's not
totally clear to me that that's guaranteed
to be the way that it goes there. There's a
bunch of different things that can happen.
One is we don't know what the political
tide will be at the national level in 2022.
It could be that this Sunday, Donald Trump at his
CPAC speech announces he's running in 2024. And
it could be that something happens between now
and 2022. And Donald Trump personally campaigns
for Marjorie Taylor Greene and she gets herself
reelected. I think anybody assuming she doesn't
is not thinking empirically at this point in time.
The other thing we have to remember, for those of
us hoping for a humiliating defeat for Marjorie
Taylor Greene in November of twenty twenty two, is
that if it's obvious that she has no shot, she
may just say she's not running for reelection
to save face. She may say, you know what, I did
my one term, unfortunately, because of the fake
news and the socialist Democrats and all of this
council culture, they are limiting my ability to
do anything. So I'm going to be able to better
work for the people by going back to Georgia and
doing who the hell knows what some lobbying gig
for. All I know, I don't know. But that is also
a sort of escape pod that if if it's abundantly
clear she's going to lose, she also just may not
run for reelection. So we just want her gone.
I don't care if she loses in 2022 or chooses not
to run, but if you're just assuming she's going
to get soundly defeated, I think you're getting
a little bit a little bit ahead of yourself there.
OK, we have a fantastic program today. I do want
to remind you, I will be live streaming CPAC on
Sunday, the final speeches of the Conservative
Political Action Conference, which will include a
speech by former President Donald Trump possibly
to announce his 2024 candidacy. I hope you will
join me Sunday for the rare weekend live stream
on YouTube, Twitter and Facebook.
But we still have a fantastic
program for you today. And we'll continue
right after this. Send me your thoughts
about the Marjorie Taylor Greene situation.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,